- Des codes QR disposés sur
les tables, des clients au bout
Dans ce restaurant réputé
pour sesmen, on vient
d'implanter un nouveau système
pour la prise de commandes.
général, Yokato Yokabai Ramen
- Donc, pas besoine
qu'un serveur vient te voir.
T'arrives avec ton téléphone,
la commande est envoyée.
ommander, il suffit
de balayer le code QR avec
un téléphone intelligent.ems duu
ici, bien listés.
- On choisit son repas puis
on paye l'addition du même coup.
- On a dqui vont sortir.
- La commande et le reçu de
vente s'impriment immédiatement.
- Ensuite, tout ce que j'ai
la commande à la cuisine.
(en japonais)
Ça nous sauve énormément
de temps, ce qui nous permet
ensuite de mieux s'occuper
du cliengrosse période d'achala,
ils n'ont pas besoin d'attendre
5-10 ou 15 minutes pour passer
une commande.
- Le système a été développé par
l'entreprise américaine Sunday,
qui a réussi à amasser
lors d'une ronde de financement
l'automne dernier.
Elle a fait l'acquisition
la montréalaise CHKPLZ quires,r,
afin de s'implanter au Canada.
CASOLI, directeur
général de Sunday au Canada
- Avec lmain-d'oeuvre qu'on voi,
partout du Canada en fait,
c'est vraiment une solution
très efficace qui aide beaucoup
- Sunday réclame aux
restaurateurs des frais de 2,5
à 3 % s
Mais le jeu en vaut
la chandelle, selon le gérant
de ce restaurant thaïlandais,
en septembre dernier.
JULES BOURGEON,
- On est un restaurant
avec beaucoup de trafic,(L(,
on a beaucoup de commandes
de commandes sur place, et donc
c'est vraiment libmps
pour que les serveurs aient
plus de temps pour s'occuper
- Mais la prise de commandes
sonne ne disparaîtra pas
demain matin.
MARTIN VÉZINA,ration Québec
- C'est sûr que s'il y aune clis
âgée, ça ne leur tente pas
nécessairement de lire
sur un téléphone.
x vont encore opter
pour un bon vieux menu papier
avec un serveur ou une serveuse
- Ici, on estime qu'un client
sur troi avec
son téléphone intelligent.
- Il y aura toujours des gens
en personne. On va toujours leur
offrir les deux po,
mais c'est certain que ça va
être de plus en plus adopté.
Radio-Canada, Mo